>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Regan Smith: Hello.
Welcome back, if you're back.
And if not, welcome the
first time to the third panel
on the Copyright Office's
roundtables for its study
on Section 1201 of the DMCA.
This topic is about renewal of
previously granted exemptions.
And before we get into the
meat of the discussion,
I just want to remind
everyone, sort of logistically,
if you would like to
speak, turn your placards
up and we'll call on you.
If you can try to limit your
comments to two to three minutes,
that will help us make sure
everyone gets a chance to speak
and we can all engage on the issues.
And the microphones, when you're
done speaking, please turn it off
to prevent feedback and we
also got a request from AV
in the last hearing to make sure
everyone speaks into the microphone
because it's being videotaped
and that will help it be
picked up on the video.
So, to start, I think we should
go around and say our names.
I'm Regan Smith, the
Associate General Counsel
of the Copyright Office.
>> Kevin Amer: I'm Kevin Amer,
Senior Counsel for Policy
and International Affairs
at the Copyright Office.
>> Andrew Moore: Andrew Moore,
a Ringer Fellow at
the Copyright Office.
>> Jason Sloan: Jason Sloan.
I'm an Attorney-Adviser
in the office of--
General Counsel's Office.
>> Regan Smith: Mr. Band?
>> Jonathan Band: I'm
Jonathan Band, here on behalf
of the Library Copyright Alliance.
>> Brandon Butler: And I'm
Brandon Butler, here on behalf
of the University of
Virginia Library.
>> Sofia Castillo:
I'm Sofia Castillo.
I'm a Staff Attorney at the
Association of American Publishers.
>> Gabe Cazares: I'm Gabe Cazares,
Government Affairs Specialist
for the National Federation
of the Blind.
>> Peter Decherney: Peter Decherney
from the University of Pennsylvania.
>> Harley Geiger: I'm Harley Geiger,
Director of Public Policy at Rapid7,
which is a cybersecurity firm.
>> Sam McClure: I'm Sam McClure.
I'm with the Stanford
Law School IP Clinic
and I'm representing the Institute
of Scrap Recycling Industries.
>> Rebecca Tushnet: Rebecca
Tushnet, the Organization
for Transformative Works.
>> Bruce Turnbull: Bruce
Turnbull, the DVD CCA,
Copy Control Association
and the Advanced Access Content
System Licensing Administrator, LLC.
>> Ben Sheffner: Ben Sheffner,
Vice President of Legal Affairs,
Motion Picture Association
of America.
>> Andrew Goldman: Andrew Goldman,
Knowledge Ecology International.
>> Regan Smith: OK.
Thank you.
I'm thinking for today's panel,
we'd like to roughly
divide the discussion
into the first half focusing on
the need for some sort of renewals,
whether this is a presumption
of renewal,
a burden shifting towards
someone opposing a renewal,
a general streamlining of a
process, whether it's administrative
or statutory reform and then getting
into specific models if possible.
I realized for this topic,
I think it might be a case
where the devil's in the details.
The Register has stated
both in her recommendation
to the last rulemaking and
in her testimony to Congress
that the public record
supports amending Section 1201
to make it easier to
renew exemptions.
She recommended congressional action
to provide a presumption in favor
of renewal in cases where
there's no meaningful opposition.
And in the comments that the
Copyright Office has received,
there seems to be, you know-- I
hate to jinx myself by saying it--
but some consensus that doing
something would be permissible
and advisable to deal with
repeated exemption requests.
But the comment is definitely
diverse in terms of what
that would look like and
how the concerns are going.
So, again, I'd like to open up
with a pretty broad question
of what would your proposal would
be or what are your concerns
with doing something to make it
easier to facilitate the renewal
of repeated requests
for an exemption.
Mr. Sheffner?
>> Ben Sheffner: Yes.
First of all, I just
want to agree with you.
I don't think it'll
jinx the panel to say
that there actually is a
remarkable degree of consensus that,
as to previously granted exemptions,
there should be some sort
of streamlined process.
The-- There's too much of a-- it's
really a waste of time and effort
and burden on both the proponents
and the Copyright Office
staff itself to have to go
through a full process when there's
really no meaningful opposition.
So, again, broad consensus
that something should be done.
And even within the details,
I don't think there are
dramatic differences.
As Bruce and I were talking
over the lunch break,
we were wondering exactly
how even a group
of opinionated lawyers are
going to be able to fill
up a full hour-and-a-half
on this particular topic.
But just a couple of points as
to how we think this should work
and sort of why we think that our
particular proposal makes sense.
As we see it, the way it
would work is that proponents
of a previously granted exemption
who seek renewal should file some--
make some very simple filing.
We're talking a page or so stating
that they would like the exemption
to be renewed and essentially
to show why they think
it should be renewed.
Again, we're talking about a very
simple one or two-page filing.
Then, there's a period of time where
if an opponent wants to come forward
and say, well, actually
we do wish to oppose this
and briefly here are the reasons,
we think there's still a substantial
debate about whether this would--
the exemption should be renewed,
then it would go throw it off back
into the regular process.
But again, if nobody came forward
to offer any meaningful opposition,
the Copyright Office,
under the existing statute,
could then just go
ahead and say, you know,
get out their renewed
stamp and be done
with that particular
request for an exemption.
The one thing I'll say
before ending is we do think
that this proposal should
be limited to renewal
of the particular exemption
that has been granted.
And in practice, that is
actually what's happened.
It's been the exceptional
case, almost a rarity
where there have been opponents
to previously granted exemptions.
I know from our perspective in
particular, this last round,
there were previously
granted exemptions
that we had opposed in the past.
Some of those we've lost on.
But if people came back
and asked for this renewal
of the previously granted exemption,
as a matter of fact,
this is no secret.
You could just look in the filings.
We did not oppose any
of those exemptions.
We would not want a proposal,
however, to apply to request
for expansions of previously
granted exemptions.
If there are new things that
people are wanting to do,
we should go through
the regular process.
And again, the burden should
remain on the proponent
of the exemption to make their case.
>> Regan Smith: OK, thank you.
Mr. Goldman?
>> Andrew Goldman: Sure.
Thanks. So KEI, we believe that
there should be presumptive renewal
of previously granted exemptions.
I think what we will
say just in response
to that is it doesn't make sense
to continue to put the burden
on the party that's already
received the exemption.
Once the exemption exists,
the burden should shift
to the copyright holder.
And I think in the previous
panel, we heard a lot of examples
of just the waste of
time, the difficulty
of understanding the
process for the parties
that are seeking the exemption
and then to continue to have to go
through that process just
seems wasteful and confusing,
especially where you have
exemptions that have been granted
that have been unopposed, as has
been the case with the exemption
for literary works distributed
electronically to be accessed
by persons who are blind, visually
impaired or print-disabled.
The exemptions, I think,
we've seen over time
and I think this was referred to
by Krista Cox in the last panel,
we've seen them get increasingly
more complex and lengthy.
In 2010, there was a 100-word
exemption for audiovisual works
which then went to
752 words in 2013.
And I don't think that
this process should be--
and KEI does not think that this
process should be so complicated
and so burdensome for
people that are trying
to make non-infringing use.
And, you know, this is
a complicated segment
of the law, even if you have a JD.
And you should not have
to have a JD in order
to have the exemption
and continue to have it.
Thanks.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Mr. Band?
>> Jonathan Band: So I'd have
to study what Mr. Sheffner's
proposal in greater detail.
But I think in broad strokes,
there's a lot of, you know,
I would agree with a
lot of what he said.
At the highest level, I agree
that there's an awful lot more
that the Copyright Office
itself can do right now
without any amendment
of the Copyright Act.
I think way too much deference
has been placed on one sentence
in one committee report
that actually was directed
to a different rulemaking, OK?
It was a rulemaking that
was going to be conducted
by NTIA, not this rulemaking.
And so, there's no need for
you to pay any deference
at all to that one sentence.
But even to the extent that
you want to pay some deference
to the de novo sentence, you know,
it's about a de novo determination,
which is sort of like
what you guys have to do
or actually what the Librarian
has to do, not what we have to do.
I mean, you could easily say,
OK, if you want a renewal,
you could just have the
whole administrative record
from the previous rulemaking just
incorporated by reference and then,
you know, then the process
in terms of the, you know,
what the Register's
recommendation and the NTIA advice
and the Librarian-- I mean, that
may be have to be somewhat de novo,
whatever that really means.
But again, I don't even
think you need to pay
that much deference
to that one sentence.
But I think, you know,
so that really could streamline
the process dramatically
and so I agree with, you know, Mr.
Sheffner's idea that, you know, if,
you know, we, if we want a
renewal, we can just do, you know,
maybe not even a page, you know,
maybe a paragraph or a sentence.
And then if, you know, even if--
I would disagree that
if there is opposition,
then it kicks back into
the normal process.
I think it should be still
somewhat of a truncated process.
I mean, I think all of the evidence
that was previously submitted
should be incorporated
so that no new evidence
needs to be submitted.
And so-- And then, you know,
if we as a proponent want
to propose additional
information, we can.
And if the opponents want to propose
additional information, they can.
But still, the whole record
should be included and considered
by the Register and the
Librarian going forward.
>> Kevin Amer: And I think
just to kind of pick up on that
and follow up, we'd be interested,
as others answer this question,
if you agree that under current
law, there is some flexibility
for the Office to, for
example, consider evidence
from the prior proceeding, is
anyone aware of any other sort
of administrative processes
that might provide an analog,
where the evidentiary record
from a prior proceeding
could be incorporated?
That would be helpful for us.
I think Professor Decherney?
>> Peter Decherney: Answer
that specific question.
>> Kevin Amer: Well, that's fine.
>> Peter Decherney: I was just going
to say that it's actually very--
time doesn't stand still.
Technology doesn't stand still.
Uses of technology
doesn't stand still.
So it's very unusual
to have a renewal
that would look exactly the same
as the exemption looked
three years ago.
But I don't think that's a
reason to throw out the proposal.
There may be another way
of saying we want to start
where we left off last time and then
think about additions or changes.
I'm not always sure that there
are even additions or expansions.
So sometimes it's just an
updating of the existing exemption
so that it accounts for
current states of technology
and the way that it's used.
And so, maybe there's just
another way of doing it
so that we don't have the same
conversation from the beginning.
We don't start at the
beginning line.
You know, we start where
we left off last time.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
So I think there's two issues,
what Kevin has followed up on
and also what you've just raised in
terms of expanding the exemption.
But I wonder if we could stick first
to see if there's some consensus
around roughly what Mr.
Sheffner proposed in terms
of a short form filing prior
to the rulemaking proper.
And I wonder Mr. Cazares,
is that something
that would work for
your organization?
>> Gabe Cazares: Sure.
So I think that that proposal
would definitely have to be flushed
out even more because, as
everybody has already stated,
what we have now is
burdensome and time-consuming,
particularly for the
community that I represent,
people who are blind
and print-disabled.
If you take a look at the record
of the last comment period,
how many comments were
submitted by organizations
or groups representing
people with disabilities
and it's demonstrably lower
than some of the other groups.
And it's because of the burdensome
evidentiary requirements,
the inconsistencies that
there have been throughout the
triennial cycles.
And I think that coming up with
a sensible proposal like the one
that has been proposed would be an
interesting conversation to have,
I think particularly for
the disability community,
who really does rely
on these exemptions.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Professor Tushnet?
>> Rebecca Tushnet: So, I want to
agree with Mr. Band and Mr. Goldman.
I think they're right
about the current law.
There's flexibility
and it's not just
because of the legislative history.
So, for example, even if
you wanted to take de novo,
as if it were in the statute,
de novo actually has a perfectly
respectable meaning for courts
that doesn't actually require any
additional factual development.
It just means de novo, right?
We don't do new fact-finding
when courts do de novo review.
And I would think that
at the very least,
that would be free for you to do.
And one thing that I have
often thought about actually
in this connection is, you
know, what is the difference
between saying, "We
would like to incorporate
by reference our submissions
from the past three rounds?"
I mean, surely that's a legitimate
way of submitting evidence.
I mean, you have it.
I mean, I can give you
another copy if you want.
But it seems like it's
still evidence to me.
And so, I see absolutely no
barrier under the current regime
to formalizing that and
acknowledging it rather
than requiring us to go through, you
know, because what we did, you know,
we just reprinted everything
and stuffed it in the appendix,
just because what else can we do?
>> Regan Smith: And then,
you also updated it too.
I mean, do you think that the
statute does require some sort
of showing of freshness of evidence?
>> Rebecca Tushnet: Absolutely not.
We did it because of the current
interpretation of de novo.
And we feared, I think, that
the Office would not see it
as sufficient if we just-- The other
thing I want to point out here is
that there's interaction here with
the proper definition of classes.
So this is something that
Professor Decherney talked about,
that if you get a definition right
in certain ways, it may not need
to be updated as often,
and therefore there can be
less sources around the edges.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Mr. McClure?
>> Sam McClure: Sure, yeah.
Thanks. Definitely broad
agreement with what's been said,
especially with what
Professor Tushnet said
about how I think the renewal
process can be streamlined
through both the legislative
history and the statute.
There are definitely
arguments for that.
I think there's a lot
of latitude there.
Two maybe small points that I
think would be really helpful
to have a discussion
about, one, the filing,
the showing by the
proponent, we actually believe
that it should just
be presumed renewed,
that there shouldn't
necessarily be a burden on a party
to file some kind of statement.
I don't know if that's serving
some kind of notice principle.
But I think there's enough notice
throughout the rest of the process
that if we just say that this
exemption is presumptively renewed
then we can move forward with
maybe some sort of process
that mirrors the existing
exemption process for--
where opponents would be filing
opposition, a meaningful opposition.
And then, with regards
to the meaningfulness,
I think there was some
statement made that as soon
as an opponent files opposition
and is sort of kicked back
into the original process, and we
just wanted to clarify and ensure
that there's some sense that the
opposition is meaningful, of course,
and that maybe, you know,
to the point that was made
by Professor Tushnet, if there
is this prior evidentiary record
that it's just getting kind of
copy/pasted into the new process,
that the opponents of the old
exemption would have to say, OK,
something significant has changed
in the facts here, you know,
to support an overturning
of that exemption.
>> Regan Smith: So you've
raised this other idea,
which is as the Register
also suggested looking at,
that there should be a
presumption of renewal
that would just become automatic.
And before we get comments on that--
or maybe people who comment on
that can compare and contrast
to what Mr. Sheffner's
proposed, which would be
that the proponents would
make a very short filing.
But it would still be a mandatory
filing from the proponents to show,
you know, very briefly why an
exemption was still needed.
So Mr. Turnbull?
>> Bruce Turnbull: Yeah.
I think I'm in agreement with my
colleague, Mr. Sheffner, on this.
And to expand a little bit and
capture some of the other comments
that have been made,
I think the notion
of bringing forward the evidence
from the record or referring to it,
you all have maintained the
online capability to go back
and see previous comments
and previous hearings
and that sort of thing.
And I-- I mean, I don't know
that we'd even need to put people
to the burden of copying it
with their current filing.
So, I mean, we'd be OK with that.
I do think under the current
statute, you would need
to have a filing to say, yes, we
want the renewal of the exemption
as opposed to the presumption.
And it seems to me that that's
a minimal enough thing and I,
you know, whether it's a sentence
or a paragraph or a page, we're--
none of us are talking
about anything terribly--
>> Jonathan Band: Billing
by the hour.
>> Bruce Turnbull: Yeah, right.
By the word, by the word.
But-- So, I don't think
that's a big burden at all.
And I think the other point,
Professor Decherney talked
about the differences.
Again, we're not-- I think
the notion, at least as far
as we're concerned,
would be that with regard
to exactly what was done
before, if there's no opposition,
no meaningful opposition to
that, that simply goes forward.
And the argument then becomes about
the difference, not about what was--
you don't go back to the whole issue
if there's opposition
to the difference.
And I think, again, that would
help both to streamline the process
and also minimize the burden
on either party in terms
of bringing evidence forward.
>> Regan Smith: OK.
Thank you.
I think next we'll
hear from Mr. Butler.
And I think to put some
more gloss on the question,
the statute requires that the
Librarian makes a determination
in a rulemaking proceeding
that persons who are users
of a copyrighted work
are or are likely to be
in the succeeding three-year
period adversely affected
by the prohibition on circumvention.
So, when I hear questions of
we could have just one sentence
or one paragraph, I wonder is that
enough under the current statute,
taking Mr. Band's comment, he thinks
there's perhaps more flexibility
permitted to say is that enough
to say this is a determination
in a rulemaking proceeding.
And also, generally
what are your thoughts
to what Mr. Sheffner has proposed?
>> Brandon Butler: Great.
So I just wanted to
raise a couple of points.
One is I think that this
process should be very--
I mean, as it has been and as
we've heard a few times today,
cognizant of who are
the participants
and how are they represented.
And so, you know, there's big
collective action problems
on the proponent side oftentimes.
You know, for example, in my clinic,
it's a different student
team every three years.
And the way that we structure
our retainers with our clients is
that representation ends the
minute we-- this process ends.
So, there's not a student
attorney that you could--
that is continually responsible
at sort of I guess faculty
and then faculty turnover and
staff at nonprofits turnover.
And so, there's a kind of a trap
for the unwary problem I'm worried
about in terms of having
to even file a one-pager,
if you're a small nonprofit
or if you're someone
who had the help of a clinic.
You know, what will you do in three
years if the person who supervised
that student team is
at the University
of Virginia instead of here?
And so, so I'm just
worried about that.
>> Regan Smith: Yeah.
>> Brandon Butler: And one
option, I think is, you know,
we file trademarks, for example.
And our trademark clients operate
under the same system, where,
you know, we represent you for x
amount of time and then we need
to let you go because
our students leave.
But we still have a kind
of institutional email address
that's on file with the PTO.
And when events happen that
might be relevant to the clients,
we make sure that we get--
we're on that notification list.
So maybe there could be a
notification system that is
where the-- when the
three years comes up,
you let the representatives
of past proponents know, hey,
the three years are coming up, you
know, and that can be an address
that everyone would keep alive.
I would think that
would be fairly simply
and there's no good
reason to not try.
>> Regan Smith: Right.
So the Office could say, give me
your email address if you want
to for the form and send
out something in advance.
>> Brandon Butler: Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, and then the other thing
I just wanted to point out is
that there's substantial
reliance on these exemptions
in pretty big institutions.
You know, at this point,
the educational exemption has been
granted and renewed for long enough
that we've-- you know,
at universities,
they've been buying DVDs and part
of the value proposition of a DVD is
that we will be able to cut clips.
And so, that's an investment.
I'm told that UVA spends about
$30,000 a year buying DVDs.
So in three years,
that's almost $100,000,
where the hope every time we
buy that DVD is that faculty
and students can make lawful uses
in accord with the exemption.
So, that's another great reason
to do the renewal is that there's
so much reliance built up.
>> Regan Smith: Is that a reason to
do the renewal or is that a reason
to perhaps like participate
in our fifth panel
and say there should be a
permanent exemption for education?
>> Brandon Butler: Oh, absolutely.
>> Regan Smith: But the reason
I ask is that, you know,
Congress is pretty clear
that this is intended
to be a failsafe mechanism that
it's intended to allow the Office
to keep their pulse on technological
developments and react.
And so, it cuts both ways,
that an exemption granted
might become ossified
or overtaken by market events.
>> Brandon Butler: Yeah.
No, I mean, make no mistake,
this is sort of a third
best solution, right?
First best is the Unlocking
Technology Act.
Second best is a permanent
exemption.
But third best is a renewal.
And I agree that the
concerns that educators have
in particular don't tend to
actually become overtaken.
So for example, VHS tapes, there
are tens of thousands of VHS tapes
that have never been issued
on a subsequent format.
And those tapes are actually still
being used lawfully under fair use.
They're being digitized and used in
clips in the same way that DVDs are.
I'm sure, like morally certain
because of the way media works,
that the same thing
will happen with DVDs.
And so, we will always, I think,
need to decrypt DVDs
in order to make clips.
I think that's just-- that's
in the nature of things,
the way media grows and changes.
>> Regan Smith: Ms. Castillo?
>> Sofia Castillo: Yes.
I have sort of three
points to discuss.
The first one is, in general,
AAP is open to some form
of streamlined proceeding or
in general, we are in agreement
with most people in the room
seemed to be so far in terms
of favoring some form of--
yeah, oh, I'm out of words--
>> Kevin Amer: A presumption of--
>> Sofia Castillo: No,
not exactly a presumption,
but some form of improving the
renewal process so that it's easier.
But one of the things that I
think might be problematic is the
suggestion that there should
be a complete burden shifting,
so that it is the opponent
who has to oppose the--
an exemption that has been
already granted for renewal.
The problem with that is that the
opponent doesn't necessarily have
all the evidence necessary to show
that the exemption is no longer
necessary-- is no longer necessary,
or has been used in the past
three years or what the likelihood
of adverse impact will be
in the next three years.
The other thing is that for any
form of streamlined proceeding
of previously granted
exemptions, the exemptions
that are renewed should be
the exact same exemption
that was approved before.
If there are any changes, of course,
there can be some form
of middle proceeding.
And I think it has
been suggested before
that it's not exactly kicked
back to what we have today,
but something in between
for additions or changes
to previously granted exemptions.
So, I think it's worth it for
the Copyright Office to sort
of contemplate having several tracks
or something along those lines.
And then the other issue I've
heard is that there seems
to be some favoring of an
automatic renewal presumption.
And the problem with that is that
then, that would be very similar
to having permanent exemptions.
And that is something
for the panel tomorrow.
But for purposes of renewal, I think
it's important to take into account
that having this proceeding every
three years is helpful to account
for changes in the marketplace.
And if we have an automatic
renewal presumption,
then that would sort
of take that away.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Mr. Geiger?
>> Harley Geiger: So, we hire
a lot of security researchers
and white hat hackers and we
also work with a large number
of independent security
researchers that we do not employ.
And most of these researchers are
working either solo or as part
of some sort of very small shop.
And most of them, the vast majority
of them do not possess the requisite
legal expertise to even deal
with cease-and-desist letters
telling them to stop their research,
often making vague claims about
DMCA, let alone for engaging
in the temporary renewal process.
So from our perspective, we
absolutely support a presumption
of renewal and it sounds like
these are the fault lines,
based on what the rest of
the panel has been saying,
and obviously where
we come down on it.
When it comes to the burden
of the initial filing,
Mr. Sheffner had suggested
that it should be the proponent
of the exemption that
makes that initial filing.
We would support an
automatic renewal.
And the idea that it would just
be one page I'm not sure is going
to hold for very long.
This is one reason why I
think that the opponents ought
to be the ones that make the filing.
That one page could
very well expand,
unless it's restricted
to a single page.
And then, every word on that
page is going to get litigated
and you will once again need
legal expertise in order
to make a good filing, one that does
not trip you up later down the line.
When it comes to the-- losing
that presumption of renewal,
we've talked about whether there
should be meaningful opposition
that cancels the presumption
of renewal.
And I don't think that
that's the right standard
because if anybody objects, which is
Mr. Sheffner's original proposition,
if anybody objects and we shunt
into the original process again,
but as we have seen in
previous rulemakings,
the same arguments are trotted
out over and over again.
There's no reason why those same
arguments would simply not be
trotted out again and then cancel
the presumption and shunt you back
into the original process.
And then, what really is
the presumption worth,
except for something that
is completely unopposed.
When it comes to-- So instead,
instead of meaningful opposition,
I think that a better
standard would be whether
or not there has been some sort of
material change in circumstances.
We've talked about
changes in the marketplace,
changes in technology and so forth.
Those types of changes are different
than simply meaningful opposition.
I think that that would
be a better standard.
>> Kevin Amer: So the-- oh, sorry.
Go ahead.
>> Harvey Geiger: Go ahead.
>> Kevin Amer: So the presumption
would kick in automatically
and then just the burden
automatically would be on opponents
to establish a material
change in circumstances?
>> Harvey Geiger: Yes, that's right.
And I'll take it a step further,
which is to say that-- two things.
One, if we're talking about
an expansion, you know,
above and beyond the
original exemption,
we think that the process ought
to then be about that expansion,
as opposed to the expansion
plus the original.
And lastly, and this goes
to the evidentiary standard
for the exemption, not just
a renewal, we don't think
that non-copyright interests that go
beyond protecting copyrighted works
or protecting the availability of
copyrighted works ought to figure
in to the denial of the
exemption, including a rebutting
of the presumption that you
would get the exemption again.
>> Kevin Amer: So, I think that
leads right into another question.
As you indicated, the proposal that
Mr. Sheffner outlined, I think,
as I understand it, is
premised on lack of opposition,
lack of meaningful opposition
or some variant of that.
Do we have another
alternative which would be--
which would provide that
the presumption would kick
in automatically.
I wonder if panelists have
views about, you know,
which model is preferable?
And if the standard is
meaningful opposition,
what would that mean exactly?
Would the Copyright Office have
some discretion to sort of--
to make a determination as to
how meaningful an opposition is?
We'd be grateful for
your thoughts about it.
Mr. Sheffner?
>> Ben Sheffner: Thank you.
So, we do oppose the idea
of a presumption of renewal
of previously granted exemptions.
And Ms. Castillo touched
on some of the reasons.
But I want to expand a little bit.
First thing I'd say is don't
necessarily listen to my reasoning.
But I would just point you back
to the Copyright Office's
own reasoning back
in the rule issued on
October 27th, 2000.
And I won't repeat what the
Copyright Office wrote here.
But in sum, the Copyright Office
looked at general principles
of statutory construction
and administrative law.
And again, summarizing, essentially
what the Copyright Office concluded
from looking at the legal
authority is that essentially
when you have a statute and then
you have exemptions to that statute
or exceptions to the statute, again,
those rules of statutory
construction
and administrative
law say that, one,
the exemption should be
construed narrowly and, two,
that the burden should be on the
proponent of those exemptions.
So, again, the Copyright
Office concluded this based
on sound legal reasoning
back in 2000.
And I don't think there has been
any change in the general principles
of statutory construction
or administrative law
that have changed.
That said, I want to emphasize
that the discussion we're having is
largely academic for two reasons.
One is, as I stated previously,
there, at least in the last round,
and I think this is sort
of becoming the practice,
there is virtually no opposition
to previously granted exemptions.
Just as a matter of fact, even those
who previously opposed an exemption
are sort of looking at the state
of affairs once it's been
granted and saying, you know what,
for whatever reason, whether we
can't come up with a showing of harm
or just a sort of political
recognition
that the Copyright
Office is not likely
to reverse a determination
they've made in the past,
we're simply not opposing that.
And the other thing I
want to emphasize is
that although the burden should
remain on the proponents, it's--
we're only talking about
a presumption here.
So if you had no presumption, you'd
assume both sides start at 50/50.
If there is a presumption-- if
there is a presumption of nonrenewal
or not a presumption in favor
of renewal, the proponents start
at 49 and the opponents at 51.
But again, as long as they make some
sort of minimal evidentiary showing
that they are entitled to that
exemption under the statute,
they will overcome that
presumption and therefore,
the Copyright Office
would be entitled to get
out of their rubber
stamp of renewal.
>> Kevin Amer: Mr. Turnbull?
>> Bruce Turnbull: I think I'd agree
with pretty much everything
that was just said.
But let me just add that, I mean,
truly it seems to me that the burden
on making the initial statement,
yes, we want to renew, I mean,
could be-- I mean, it could
be a checkbox on a form.
And if the Copyright Office emails
that form to the prior proponent
and says, do you want to renew
exactly what you got before,
and you check the box, I
mean, as far as I'm concerned,
that would be a sufficient filing.
I really did not mean this
to be any kind of a burden.
I mean, that's the-- but it seems
to me that under the statute,
you do need to go through
the process
of actually getting a request.
You can use, as we said before,
the prior evidentiary record
as the basis for that.
That satisfies the
requirement that this be done
in a rulemaking, it seems to me.
And the opposition-- I'm sort
of trying to come up with--
I understand the point about making
the same argument all over again.
I-- That does seem to be a
waste of everybody's time,
except maybe for the lawyer
who bills by the hour.
But the-- So, there is some
kind of changed circumstances,
changed argument, there was a
change in the law that something
that people thought was fair
use was found not to be fair use
or there was an abuse
of the prior exemption
or somebody actually came
forward with a circumvention tool
that would turned out to be a
huge problem in the marketplace.
I mean, those are the kinds of
things that I can imagine often
as an opponent coming
forward and saying, hey,
you really ought to
look at this again.
Those are the kinds of
changes that I would see
as needing to be brought forward.
That's not a matter of presumptions
or burden shifting in my view.
It's just a matter of
practical, as has been said,
as a practical matter, you know,
DVD CCA has not opposed the previous
exemptions that were granted
and I don't foresee
doing so in the future.
Again, absent some specific change.
And there, I think we ought
to be able to come forward
and say there's been a
change and here it is.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Mr. Band, do you want to speak
following up on this question
of whether, you know, the ease of
showing whether there's changed
or unchanged circumstances
as sort of a precondition
to renewing an exemption?
>> Jonathan Band: Yes.
So, it seems to me that to some
extent this whole discussion of,
you know, presumptions and burden
shifting is not really appropriate
to a rulemaking.
I mean, you know, those are terms
that are much more appropriate
to an adjudicatory proceeding.
And this rulemaking has, for
whatever reason, has over time taken
on more and more of this
adjudicatory quality to it.
But it's really not necessary.
And, you know, it seems
that, you know,
getting back to your earlier
question about, you know, yes,
the statute would require
the Librarian
to make a determination
that, you know, there's--
harm is occurring or
is likely to occur.
I mean, to some extent, that
can, in this renewal context,
can occur if the checked box says
do you want to renew this exemption
because you are being harmed
or likely to be harmed
over the next three years.
And then, that would seem to
me, you know, just on its face,
that statement plus
the incorporation
of the administrative record from
the previous would be sufficient
for the Librarian, on the basis
of sort of making, you know,
looking at-- I mean, I don't-- I
wouldn't-- I'm not sure I would go--
I think if we just-- the
rubber stamp is probably not--
might not pass APA muster, but that
the Librarian, based on that record,
would say, well, you know, a good
case was made three years ago.
There doesn't seem to be
any changed circumstances.
These people say that they're
likely to be harmed again.
OK, I will approve it.
I don't think we need to
start getting into, you know,
burden shifting, presumption,
all that kind of stuff.
Now, it is conceivable that someone
will come out of the woodwork
and say, no, I don't
want this renewed.
And again, we're talking--
now, I agree that if we want an
exemption expanded, you know,
that's on us to talk about
why it should be expanded.
But if we're just talking about,
you know, the renewal of, you know,
the renewal of the existing
one, you know, then--
you know, conceivably if someone
comes in and says, no, you know,
it shouldn't be renewed,
you know, that's something
that the Register would look
at in the recommendation
to see whether they
made a sufficient--
you know, whether what they
said was sufficiently compelling
about changes or whatever.
But in conceivably in, you know,
the notice soliciting comments,
you would explain the
kinds of things
that you would be looking for.
But again, I don't think
we need to start talking
about evidentiary burdens
or anything of the sort.
I mean, these would be things that
would be considered in the course
of this determination, in a
rulemaking context as opposed
to an adjudicatory context.
>> Regan Smith: Well, so I
think with the check the box
and rubber stamp, we've
lightened the workload
of the Copyright Office.
But I think--
>> Jonathan Band: Which
is our objective.
That's why we're all here.
>> Regan Smith: Well, that's great.
But from a rulemaking perspective,
I wonder if we can speak a
little bit more about, you know,
whether this-- the Office has
previously said that a declaration
of unchanged circumstances
could be considered
in renewing any exemption.
Are there ways we could use that or
build upon that to make the renewal
of previously granted
exemptions easier?
So Professor Tushnet?
>> Rebecca Tushnet: So
you asked earlier on,
and I think this is
another version of it,
whether a one-page statement
could meet the statutory burden
as the Office has interpreted it.
And I think the answer
is absolutely yes, right?
If it says nothing has changed.
In other administrative proceedings,
facts that aren't contested
are routinely accepted,
even without going
back to the bedrock.
I mean, certainly, if you do want to
look at the PTO as a model, in fact,
you can rely on things
like a statement
of five years of uncontested use.
The PTO can actually rely
on that not just to say
that there's been five
years of uncontested use,
but that that has a legal
consequence that the mark
at issue has developed
a secondary meaning.
So, it's actually perfectly
standard to accept things like that.
Now, I also would like
to say a little bit
about the meaningful
opposition question.
So, this is just specific
to our experience
with the remix exemptions.
What we hear in the remix exemption
proceedings is the statement our
arguments about the facts and
the law apply to both existing
and proposed exemptions, but
we do not oppose renewal.
And if you go back and look,
you'll see that structure
in basically everyone's,
opponent's comments.
And one question I would have
for this meaningful opposition
standard is, how are we going
to interpret a claim like that?
Does that represent
meaningful opposition
to the existing exemption?
Since it's an argument against
it, would we just not take
in to its logical conclusion?
And let me just with my
law professor hat on,
so if the evidence is
relevant to both the existing
and proposed expansions, then an
adjudicatory model does allow you
to ignore that fact
because parties are allowed
to make strategic concessions,
right?
But a rulemaking model might not.
And so, one thing at issue here is
to decide what this
proceeding will be.
And once we have a
better grasp on that,
some of the answers will follow.
But I think right now,
we actually are,
as Jonathan was saying,
we go back and forth.
Some is adjudicatory.
Some is rulemaking.
You know, and that's part
of what makes it difficult.
And then relatedly, just again
for the remix specifically,
in terms of meaningful opposition,
as a practical matter, you know,
I expect that the opponents will
always come back saying, hey,
there's a new screen
cap program out,
you know, there's a new processor.
It's faster and it's better.
And, you know--
>> Regan Smith: But
you've heard next to you--
>> Rebecca Tushnet: Yeah.
>> Regan Smith: -- the general
opponents saying they don't do that.
They don't oppose the existing ones.
>> Rebecca Tushnet: But if-- I
encourage you then to go back
and look at the comments
because they're absolutely right.
They're saying they don't oppose it.
But the arguments they make--
and they say this too--
the arguments they make
apply to both the existing
and the proposed extension
but they are not opposing.
And so, one question for you
as decision-maker is what
consequences ought that concession,
if it is a concession, have?
Right, does that count?
>> Regan Smith: Sure, and I
mean, just since our goal is
to build consensus, I think in
the past, the Office took them
at their word when they said they
were not opposing and held them
to that as opposed to saying,
well, some of your arguments
on the expansions would
apply to the existing.
>> Rebecca Tushnet: Well, so, and I
understand, and my point is simply
that that makes sense in
an adjudicative model.
But if you're really
thinking about this
as being a rulemaking fact-finder
with independent fact-finding
obligations,
then that is an intrusion
into the model.
And at the very least, we
should talk openly about that.
And this is somewhat a statement
against one's interests, I admit.
But, you know, I'd like
to know the answer.
>> Kevin Amer: Mr. McClure?
>> Sam McClure: I'd just like to
make one more quick comment maybe
about the idea of presumptive
renewal, which is that it's--
an organization is
tied to this exempt--
if you don't presumptively renew,
then you have one organization,
the original proponent perhaps,
being tied to this exemption,
you know, process after process.
And I think the point was made
by Mr. Butler and Mr. Geiger
that once the exemption
is granted, it's something
that benefits the public at large
who falls within that class, right?
It shouldn't have to be one
organization that comes back
and year after year, you
know, sort of lives in fear
that someone is going to
present meaningful opposition
and they're going to go
back into this, you know,
hundred-hour, thousand-hour process.
So, to the extent that an exemption
would be presumptively renewed,
the burden on that particular
organization would be relieved.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr.-- Professor Decherney?
>> Peter Decherney: I just
want to expand a little bit
on Professor Tushnet's point.
The structure of the comments
I've seen from the DVD CCA,
the MPAA is always we're--
in theory, we're not
opposed to the renewal.
But we think it could be limited
in these 10 ways, 20 ways.
And we actually spend a tremendous
amount of time refuting each
of those ways in which
it would be limited.
And much of the hearing time
is spent discussing those.
So even though it says
it's not an opposition,
it is in fact opposition.
Just one other structural
issue, which I know--
we mentioned it in comments
but it hasn't come up here
and I just wanted to
bring it up is, you know,
if you do a brilliant job
drafting the previous exemption,
then you've actually eliminated
this problem for three years.
And so, it's hard to
show that the harm
that existed three
years prior still exists
because the problems
have been solved.
You can show that the exemption
has been taken, made use of
or caused problems,
led to infringement.
But you can't show the exact
same harm that was there before.
>> Regan Smith: So you think you
can't show unchanged circumstances
because you made the--
>> Peter Decherney: I mean, that's
true in life in general, yes.
[ Laughter ]
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Mr. Turnbull?
>> Bruce Turnbull: I think the
point's been made about the nature
of the filing in the
comments and I-- fair points.
And I think the Office has
appropriately taken those,
as was indicated.
I think the procedure
that we're now talking
about would probably eliminate
that approach to the comments
because you'd be forced up
front to either say, you know,
there are meaningful differences
and there are changes or not.
And so, I think that the
procedure would naturally eliminate
that sort of problem.
I think the-- And then, would
force us to say, well, gee,
is there really a change that we
want to argue here with regard
to the old exemption or is it
something where we want to say no,
that we're only going to argue with
regard to whatever the change is.
And I understand that that--
And the points that have
been made are fair on that.
The other thing is,
I mean, throughout--
sending an email to a previous
applicant with a checkbox,
I wouldn't rule out
somebody else coming in
and saying I've been
taking advantage of this
and I want this renewed, even if the
organization that originally filed--
I didn't mean to preclude that.
I was just trying to be
helpful in making it easier.
So, I think, you know,
anybody who can represent
that they are taking
advantage of the exemption
and believe it should be renewed as
previously stated ought to be able
to make that application.
And then, we would have to decide
whether there's a reason to oppose.
>> Kevin Amer: Mr. Cazares?
>> Gabe Cazares: So, from
the perspective of people
with disabilities, I know
that the National Federation
of the Blind fully supports
presumptive automatic renewal.
I think many at this table
remember the 2010 cycle
when another disability
organization,
the American Foundation
for the Blind, was very--
came very close to
losing the exemption
that they had previously renewed
because of evidentiary requirements.
So I think there's something
to be said for taking
into account the points that
have already been raised
by the Copyright staff and other
panelists about the statute
and the limitation that the
Librarian has to keep in mind.
I think it's safe to say,
particularly for blind
and print-disabled individuals,
that within three years,
our status as blind
and print-disabled people
really isn't going to change,
and that it can be argued that
we would be adversely affected
by not having an exemption.
So, I think that NFB fully
supports what Mr. Goldman
and others have already brought up.
But there is something to be
said about finding some mechanism
where we can simply say
we're requesting an exemption
under the given rules.
Now, not to bring up another point,
I think it's important to consider
where the burden of
proof is right now.
I think Mr. Band made a really
good point that this is more
of an adjudicatory issue.
But because of-- that's-- because
these are the circumstances
that we have now, I think
there is something to be said
from shifting the burden
from the, first,
from the proponent
to the opposition.
So, I just wanted to make
sure that that was clear,
at least for people
with disabilities.
>> Kevin Amer: Thank you.
Mr. Geiger?
>> Harley Geiger: So, it sounds
like we've heard some more consensus
than perhaps we had
originally thought
on what meaningful
opposition ought to look like
and perhaps it should be something
more like a change in circumstances.
So I want to draw back to an
earlier comment that I've made,
which I know relates to also to the
panel on the evidentiary standard,
which is that in thinking
about whether
to renew a temporary exemption,
it's our position that interests
that do not have anything to do
with protecting rights-holders
or making copyrighted works
available, we do not think
that those should be considered
for denying the exemption.
In addition-- Or, you
know, or at least have them
as a very clearly carrying
much lower weight.
From the perspective of security
researchers, most of the opposition
that we have seen so far to
the exemption that we had asked
for relates not at all to copyright.
It is about safety largely.
So we have, for example, a
vehicle practice and we're looking
at cybersecurity flaws
in vehicles with the goal
of making those vehicles safer.
We saw opponents talking about
the possibility that owners
of cars would circumvent emissions
controls or modify their vehicles
in a way that is not safe.
These things are already illegal.
In the last panel, it was brought
up, well, what about the hacker
that says they want to hack
the nuclear power plant.
That's also illegal.
That's all illegal under the
Computer Fraud and Abuse Act.
By in large, the DMCA we're
talking about are computers
that the security researcher
already owns.
And copyright law and 1201 are
not the appropriate tool to use
to protect these non-copyright
interests.
There are already specific
government agencies
with greater expertise and in
many cases already regulations
on the books prohibiting
these very same kinds of acts.
So, that is our position,
not accommodating non-copyright
interests for denying the exemption.
>> Regan Smith: In the specific
case of security researchers,
1201(j) is a permanent exemption.
And I know you're going
to speak tomorrow.
I mean, is that perhaps a better
avenue to just sort of update
that to the extent it needs updated
so that security researchers can
rely on it as opposed to, you know,
tinkering with the whole mechanism
of the rule-making process?
>> Harley Geiger: One
hundred percent, yes.
And I mean, I'm in
the same position as--
>> Regan Smith: Mr. Butler.
>> Harley Geiger: --
Mr. Butler that we think
that this is less preferable than
updating the permanent exemption.
Part of the problem with, you know,
even a change in circumstances is
that technology will evolve.
Security research will also evolve.
It will present new circumstances,
probably not new circumstances
related
to making copyrighted works
available, but new circumstances,
new safety dangers,
things like that.
And those safety dangers should
be dealt with by the agencies
that are directly responsible
for working on safety.
So yes, 100%, the permanent
exemption.
We have specific ideas on how
to change it and we can talk
about it tomorrow or
now if you wish.
>> Regan Smith: Let's
save it for tomorrow.
>> Harley Geiger: Sure.
>> Harley Smith: Go ahead.
>> Jason Sloan: I just have a quick
question going back to relying
on the prior record from when the
exemption was originally granted.
Is there some point
in time when relying
on that old record would get stale?
You know, it seems maybe if
you're relying on the market
from three years ago,
it might still be OK.
But what about when
you're 10 years, 20 years,
because it keeps getting
renewed without opposition?
At least working within
the current statute,
it says that the determination is
whether users are or are likely
to be adversely affected.
So at what point-- Is there
some point when relying
on that old record and a checkbox,
does that become problematic
within the current statute?
Mr. Band.
>> Jonathan Band: So what
I would imagine that even
after checking the
box, that those of us--
someone in Washington will
show up at the hearing.
And so--
>> Regan Smith: I don't think
we don't have the hearing
if you check the box, though.
I think that's what we're--
>> Jonathan Band: Well, no, I'm--
>> Peter Decherney: -- no hearing.
>> Jonathan Band: Well, right, or
you could-- I mean, it could be--
you know, we can meet for
lunch over in the cafeteria.
And, you know, but it could
be something very, you know,
if there's a sense that
there's needs to be refreshing
of the record, that
can easily be done.
It doesn't need to be-- The
point is it doesn't need to be--
We don't need to make this more
complicated than it needs to be.
Let's keep it simple.
And so, I think the idea of, you
know, if you want to say, OK,
let's have a quick hearing, you
know, I'll come in on behalf of,
you know, the education
community or, you know,
I can work on behalf of the blind.
I mean, someone can come in and
we can talk about it and say,
are you still using this exemption.
Yeah, we're still using it.
You know, Rebecca can
come in and say are-- is--
are people still making remixes?
Yeah. They're still making remixes.
It doesn't need to be, you know--
and the possibility, you know,
so there's someone who can come in.
This is a question of does
Rebecca have to come forward
with all these examples of
remixes that have been made
in the last three years or does
the NFB have to come forward
with statistical data on
the number of blind people
who are making use of the exemption.
I mean, it's that kind of burden.
But, you know, it's a problem
that can easily be addressed
down the road if necessary.
>> Regan Smith: I mean, the
only thing I will say is given
that we have to have these
as a triennial rule-making,
which means every three years,
to have the short and then
like the medium and then the long
I think could get complicated
very quickly.
So any reform I think the
Office would want to make sure
that it's not increasing
the complexity
of an already complex rule-making.
So I don't know if you wanted
to speak to that, but--
>> Jonathan Band: Just to--
>> Regan Smith: Yeah.
>> Jonathan Band: Related to
that, I mean, the other way--
not only is it a matter of
these renewals but you could--
again, in my interest of
reducing your workload, the--
you can reduce the number of
categories or number of classes.
So, you know, we've had--
we've grown from one class
that basically covered
all educational uses
and documentary films and
remixes and noncommercial works
and now there's probably,
I don't know, like eight
or nine classes covering that.
You know, we could go back to--
or at some point, come up with one
class and just keep things simple.
Certainly, in the case of if
you look at the, you know,
the 22 exemptions granted
in this past rule-making,
more than half dealt
with embedded software.
We don't need to have
11 or 12 exemptions.
You could have one, you know,
properly crafted would
take care of that problem.
And you won't have to worry about
regulating the automobile industry.
You know, let someone else do that.
That's not your job.
And so, but the point is, you know,
these things can work in tandem
to really streamline
this whole process.
>> Regan Smith: Professor Tushnet?
>> Rebecca Tushnet:
So Jonathan-- sorry.
Jonathan covered almost
exactly what I wanted to say.
But let me just reinforce that by
linking it with Mr. Cazares' point,
which is, you know, it's not
just patterns of protected use--
of classes that persist over
time, but patterns of uses persist
over time, which is why we talk
about things that are, you know,
non-infringing or categories
of fair use.
So people have really mapped
those pretty well, Pam Samuelson,
Michael Madison, they've done it.
And those can be expected
to persist over time.
In terms of, you know,
don't complicate an
already complicated rule,
I think what we are saying is, you
know, if you change the definition
so that they're 44 words long,
again, like they used to be,
then you wouldn't-- then even having
a short, medium and long form,
which I don't think you should do,
would actually represent
a substantial improvement.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
So I'll call on Mr. Sheffner
next and I wanted to just tee
up the next question, which
is how should we separate--
whether there's an administrative or
statutory, you know, change dealing
with new exemptions, you know, or
new technologies, the expansions
versus the renewal of a
previously granted exemptions.
Because I think, again, some of
it is that technology does evolve
and this rule-making process
is supposed to be able
to accommodate those evolutions.
>> Ben Sheffner: Right.
So, I just wanted to address
briefly Mr. Sloan's question
about sort of stale, old evidence.
I mean, like Mr. Turnbull, we would
not oppose the ability of proponents
to incorporate by reference
evidence that has been submitted
in previous rule-makings.
So, is it possible that
evidence could get stale?
Yes. It is.
But I think that the-- it's
largely a self-correcting mechanism.
This is I would envision a
revised system and it's this.
So, if a proponent goes in
there and files their one-page
or one-checkbox form, however it
turns out, and they say, you know,
and we hereby incorporate
by reference all the stuff
that we filed in the
previous rule-makings,
the potential opponents of that
exemption will look at that.
And in deciding whether
or not they're going
to oppose this previously
granted exemption,
one of the things they will ask
themselves is has the situation
on the ground changed.
It could be a change
in the case law.
in business models.
It could be that there's new
technology that enables you
to do what you want to do
without circumventing DRM.
And it could be that the evidence
that was submitted truly is stale
and doesn't reflect the
current situation on the ground.
And if it is and that would,
again, what I think is going
to be a very rare instance
of opposing a previously
granted exemption,
they would have the opportunity
to do it and say, you know what,
we actually do have
meaningful opposition here.
We think the situation has changed
for the following three reasons.
And, you know, there are actually
the evidence they incorporate
by reference is indeed stale.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Did you also want to comment
on the second question,
which should be what about a
new technology, for example,
if there is a petition for
an exemption for, you know,
4K versus we're renewing
something for DVDs?
How should the rule-making
process deal with renewal
of the previous exemption
as well as consider some
of the issues with a new petition?
>> Ben Sheffner: Sure.
I think I touched on
this in my answer
to your very first question
this afternoon, and it's this.
We would support a streamlined
process for dealing with sort
of renewal of the exact
same exemption.
To the extent people want to expand
that exemption, I think they're--
in practice, it may be streamlined
because the part of the renewed--
I mean, if you have an exemption--
a previously granted
exemption asks for this.
And then, they requested
new exemption is this,
what I'm saying is we don't
have to fight again over this.
But to the extent that they
ask for this much more, yes,
we think the burden should remain
on the proponents of the exemption.
And you know, we'll go through
the regular process about that.
It'll be a lot smaller
of a fight than having
to fight over the whole thing.
It will just be fighting
over this much.
But again, the sort of streamlined
part should only technically apply
to exactly what was
previously granted.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Mr. Butler?
>> Brandon Butler: Yeah.
So and I think that's largely true
that certainly the presumption
of renewal, you know, that we've all
sort of agreed on would not apply
in the same way to an
incremental increase so,
going from the existing
DVD and Blu-Ray to 4K.
But on the other hand, I would
hope that some of the logic
that underwrites that presumption
logic that we've all sort of come
to agree to would mean
that that process would--
that the arguments about 4K
or whatever the new format is
could be a little bit shorter
because we would all already agree
that the planned use
is lawful, right?
Like if it's fair use with a DVD,
it's also fair use with a Blu-Ray,
it's also fair use with a 4K.
So, that would already
be established.
And the adverse effect, some of the
sense of what is the pedagogical use
of media in a media class, right,
all of that stuff would
already be on the record.
So hopefully, it would be a much
shorter argument about, you know,
why if anything-- what, if anything,
makes 4K different from DVD
or Blu-Ray in terms of meriting
an exemption or whatever.
>> Regan Smith: Mr. Turnbull?
>> Bruce Turnbull:
Actually, I think I agree
with most of what you just said.
I think the-- from the
technology provider, however,
there is a substantial
difference between a technology
that is 10 years old
and a technology
that has just been launched
and the considerations.
And we think that the Copyright
Office should and has made
with regard to new technologies
and the harm to the development
of the market-- again, going
back to the original purpose
of the circumvention provision
of the DMCA, which is not merely
to stem piracy, but also
to enable new markets.
And so, the enabling
of the new market
for 4K may have a different dynamic
than the situation with regard
to Blu-Ray, which is
now 10 years old.
So, I think that-- I do think
that there's a substantial
difference between, you know,
and you can't just sort
of automatically apply whatever the
reasoning was with regard to DVD
and then Blu-Ray and
then, you know, whatever.
>> Regan Smith: OK.
So Mr. Band, it seemed like
Mr. Butler and Mr. Turnbull
at least agreed on something.
Do you want to undo that or--
>> Jonathan Band: Oh, no, no, no.
I just want to basically-- and this
is kind of very difficult for me
to be in the situation
of agreeing so much
with Mr. Turnbull and Mr. Sheffner.
But the-- I just think,
you know, getting back--
one of the things that you can
do in building on, you know,
the issues that, you know, Bruce has
identified is that in this process,
the, you know, the Copyright
Office can help manage--
and again, with the aim of
reducing your workload, OK,
you know by now what the issues are
in general terms with, you know,
this whole DVD/Blu-Ray, you know,
educational use, remix
use and so forth.
So you know, one can easily imagine
that, you know, there's going to be,
you know, we'll make, you know,
say we want to renew
plus we want to expand.
And then, they'll say, well, we
have no problem with renewal.
OK. We have this issue
with expansion.
And then, you know,
there could almost be
like a pre-hearing conference
where you guys say, OK,
this is what we think, you know,
we want to hear this, we want to,
you know, where you can sort of
iron out, figure out what it is
that you need to know from us.
And that way, it could ultimately
reduce our burden with respect to--
but the point is it could
reduce your burden as well.
You know, we're talking-- in
terms of what's being renewed,
we're talking about a relatively
small universe of things
that we know now have been, you
know, so that this cluster of the,
you know, motion picture-related
issues, the issues with respect
to the, you know, screen readers.
You know, maybe one or two others.
And so, there's nothing-- I don't
see why you can't have at some point
in the process a meeting with us
where we kind of say, OK, this is--
what is it that you
need more and what is it
that we're going to give you more.
And so, that way, it will just,
you know, instead of, again,
sort of like reinventing the wheel,
we can really move the
process along dramatically.
>> Regan Smith: So, it sounds
like you're saying short
of a statutory reform, if the
Office provided some guidance as to,
you know, what quantum
of information we thought would
be useful for the Register
to make the recommendation to the
Librarian, you know, in advance
or maybe sort of iteratively
working with the parties,
that that could be helpful to
streamlining this and avoiding
for the renewals, the type
of rulemaking process we
had for the new petitions.
>> Jonathan Band: Yeah.
No, I think that that's right.
But again, it's-- I'm trying to push
you to be a little more informal.
And I think that that could make
the process work a lot better.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Mr. Butler, anything to add or--
>> Brandon Butler: I just
wanted to add that the flipside
of what Mr. Turnbull was
saying about, you know,
when a format is young, it's--
the market realities about that
format will be thus and such.
And there will be a similar-- there
will be, of course, a mirror image
on the side of the proponents.
When a format is young, the kinds
of harms that we've typically shown
for young formats are, you
know, there are these titles
that are not available on the-- you
know, right-- and we're told like,
well, that's just one or two titles.
Well, it's because
it's a young format.
So, there's an interesting mirror
image thing that happens here
and maybe these young
formats really will benefit
from getting their own
kind of hearing where all
of that stuff can come out.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Mr. Sheffner, did you
want to add something?
>> Ben Sheffner: No, I'm sorry.
>> Regan Smith: Oh, nope?
OK. Mr. Turnbull, good?
>> Bruce Turnbull: Yeah.
I mean, I-- we're having this
wonderful agreement session here.
And I think that what Mr. Band
was talking about would make sense
and would be helpful
in streamlining.
I mean, I think that, again, the--
and getting and having some kind
of process with the Office to sort
of work with the parties to say, OK,
what makes the most sense to have
a hearing about would make sense.
I did want to comment just briefly
on the nature of the rulemaking.
And this has always been sort
of a hybrid in a lot of respects
between sort of the
adjudicatory model
and the notice-and-comment
rulemaking model.
And it seems to me that that's
sort of inevitable in the process
because I think it's unrealistic
nor do I think Congress thought
that it was going to happen, that
the Copyright Office would go out
and know what, you know, 200
million people might be doing
with any given copyrighted work.
And so, the people who have the need
and to use something are the people
with the information to come
forward and say, this is how we want
to use it and this is why
this is a problem for us.
And, you know, at the
end of the day,
the Copyright Office has the
obligation to come out with a rule
that reflects the evidence and, you
know, notwithstanding the comments
about the Commerce
Department report,
I think that is very
instructive still.
You know, they talk several
places about evidence
and about a record and
that sort of thing.
So I think that having evidence
in the record is an important
element of this rulemaking.
But it is-- In other respects,
it doesn't have the sort
of adjudicatory feel to it.
One of the comments that was made
earlier, I think by Mr. Williams,
about the possibility of then
having a proposed rule, you know,
put forward would then sort
of maybe complete the cycle.
That would then feel more like
the notice-and-comment rulemaking.
But all of the rest of it leading
up to it would be fact-finding
that the Office would need in
order to know what to put forward
in a proposed rulemaking.
And we would be OK with that
as a process and we're OK
with the process mostly
as it is but.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
So, the next question I feel
will probably spark dissent.
One of the participants--
ESA is not on this panel--
had suggested a streamlined process
for rejecting a proposal, saying,
you know, just as we renew
exemptions, we also will end
up rehashing the same
proposals over and over again
that are consistently
recommended against.
Should we have a similar
streamlining proposal for, you know,
a second bite at the apple
of something that was denied.
>> Rebecca Tushnet:
So, a couple of things.
I mean, in general, no,
in part because the copyright owner
always retains the ability to go
to court and hash that out and win
either on contributory infringement
or infringement, depending
on what the activity is.
And that would end the
exemption and end it next time,
whereas if you lose, you
just don't get that chance.
So, it's structurally
unequal in a way
that makes mirror image
treatment inappropriate.
The other thing though is
that considering this rule again
requires you to consider the way
that all these little
additions have been piled
on to specific exemptions
over the years.
So, does that mean, for
example, are you proposing
that we could not go back
to the 44-word initial
educational exemption?
That seems to me like a bad idea,
just because it's been loaded
down with other things doesn't mean
that the initial exemption
was inappropriate,
even though in some
sense, it's been rejected.
And I think the kind of
line-drawing that you would end
up doing would be contrary to
the goal of simplifying things.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Mr. Band?
>> Jonathan Band: I guess, I
would add to that that the--
a problem with sort of like a
streamlined rejection is that the,
you know, circumstances do change.
And I suspect also that
rights-holders get more comfortable
with certain kinds of activities.
And so, just to-- if a proponent
is willing to go through the work
of amassing new evidence, then,
you know, the rights-holder,
if they're confident that their
arguments were sound before,
they can-- I mean, certainly
they can always incorporate
by reference say, well,
all the argument--
you know, these people
haven't said anything new.
So it's not-- you know, we're
not streamlining the process but,
you know, once you make it clear
it's OK to incorporate things
by reference or if they want to,
you know, resubmit the same thing,
if it really is just the same thing
all over again, then, you know,
the arguments as to why it wasn't
valid before would apply now,
whereas in our situation,
it's, you know, it's different
because we have to-- you know, right
now, you're basically telling us
that we have to de novo
show that we're going
to be adversely affected.
So we have to come up with sort of
like new examples of how we're using
or how we've been using
it in the last three years
as opposed to previously.
So, that's why the
symmetry, you know,
it is an asymmetrical situation.
And, you know, so certainly, it
could be done in a way, you know,
you could make it clear that
there are ways, you know, if--
where they can, if they
want to, incorporate stuff
by reference, that's fine.
But still, the need
for a streamlined process
I think is very different.
>> Regan Smith: Mr.
Butler, do you agree?
>> Brandon Butler: Largely, yeah.
Yeah. I think the key thing is
just, you know, the incentive to--
the difficulty rather
of seeking an exemption
that has not been previously
granted is high enough I think
to deter folks from--
you know what I mean?
That's enough of a burden, that
you had better really want it
and really believe it.
And so, you know, I
think at that point,
those folks should be able
to get into the process.
And the people who don't have enough
of an interest will be deterred
by the difficulty of doing it.
>> Regan Smith: I mean, you
would be surprised sort of.
[ Laughter ]
We do get a lot of repeat players.
>> Jason Sloan: I have
a quick question.
I just want to go back to the issue
of meaningful opposition and what
that would mean and what would need
to be shown in those circumstances.
So, we had talked about,
you know, showing something,
either that it's-- the
exemption is not being used,
there have been changed
circumstances or harm
or something to that effect.
But I wanted to get your
positions on how much evidence--
how much opposition would be needed.
It seems that if you had something
like a preponderance standard
and the proponent is just checking a
box saying unchanged circumstances,
it would be a-- could be a pretty
minimal showing to oppose that.
So, I just wanted to
get your viewpoints
on where the line should be
that would make the presumption
of meaningful in that
the opposition needs
to have something fairly
substantive, but not also--
but then, on the other side, not be
a huge burden then on the opponent
such that you could never
really oppose the presumption
where that line might be best drawn.
>> Sam Mcclure: Sure.
Well, I think-- and you can correct
me if I'm wrong, but you were saying
that the proponent, short of a very
short showing, is going to just say
like the check the box of the
opponent, to kick that back is just
to have to overcome
the check the box.
>> Jason Sloan: Right, to
get to more likely than not
against a checked box
would seem pretty minimal.
So, I'm just trying to see
where the line might be
to give both sides a chance--
>> Sam Mcclure: Absolutely.
And I just-- I think certainly,
ISRI and I'm sure many other people
on this panel would want
the Copyright Office
to be considering the past
evidentiary record, you know,
and have that form the basis
of whatever determination
of meaningfulness the
Copyright Office comes to.
So, I think it's really
hard to decide this question
without having a super
clear idea of how much
of that evidentiary record
is kind of just pulled
into this new discussion
versus the proponent having
to say affirmatively,
we've shown this before.
You know, here it is again.
But I think our position
would definitely be
that the meaningful opposition
would have to show some kind
of significance change
in circumstances
such that the prior evidentiary
record is overcome to some degree.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
I think we're going to
try to do one last round.
In the spirit of efficiency
that we've been talking about,
we can maybe end a
couple of minutes early.
Mr. Band?
>> Jonathan Band: Well, I
guess the way I would respond
to that question is I'm
not sure you really need
to specify the exact
precise level of, you know,
how material the opposition
is or how significant it is.
You know, if, you know, Mr. Turnbull
or Mr. Sheffner's client, you know,
if they make a submission as to why
something should not be renewed,
you'll look at it and you'll
decide whether it is material
or whether it has weight or not.
And then, you'll decide
whether to kick it over.
You know, because this
is all going to be--
and I'm not sure how there
would be a possibility
of us challenging your decision
whether or not to kick it over,
right, whether to put it
in the streamlined process
or the other process.
I think it would be very hard for us
to come up with a court challenge.
So given that you're going to
have a fair degree of discretion,
it's going to be very
hard for us to show
that you somehow abused
your discretion, you know,
going one way or the other.
I mean, it would have to be
pretty blatant, like, oh,
there Band goes again,
let's, you know, screw him.
You know, but barring that, I
don't think it would be very--
you know, so I don't think it--
again, I think, let's
keep it simple.
Let's not make it so complicated
that we get tied up in standards
and burdens such that we,
you know, don't move forward.
I think we're in a position where
we could move forward pretty easily
and not worry about those,
you know, those nuances.
>> Regan Smith: Mr. Sheffner?
>> Ben Sheffner: Yeah.
I largely agree with
what Mr. Band just said.
And just to respond to Mr.
Sloan's question about sort
of what meaningful
opposition would look like.
You know, we were not terribly
specific in our own written comments
about exactly how the
process should work.
But let me just sort of spell it
out how I envision in
kind of non-legalese.
I mean, what I envision
is essentially a sort
of prescreening process that the
Copyright Office would employ before
delving into sort of the regular
process that we've all gotten used
to over the last six cycles or so.
So, the initial step
would be the proponent
of a previously granted
exemption filing something short.
We can argue about whether
it's a page or a checkbox
or a paragraph or whatever.
And then, the-- essentially what
the Copyright Office is going
to be asking itself, or
should be asking itself,
is do we have a real fight here.
Do we have a real fight between
sort of two sets of arguments
or do we have essentially an
unopposed request for an exemption?
So, the opponent of the
previously granted exemption,
again in this rare case where
someone is actually going
to come forward and oppose a
previously granted exemption,
I would just say, again, it's
going to be a one-page form
and they're going to identify why
there is meaningful opposition here.
Is it because that there's,
you know, a short description,
there is a change--
they've discovered that
there's actually great harm
or significant harm from
the previously granted--
from the exception to the
prohibitions in the DMCA?
Is there a changed case law
that would touch on whether
or not the use at issue
was non-infringing?
Is there new technology that would
make possible what the proponents
want to do without
circumventing the DRM?
That kind of thing.
Again, a short form that allows
the Copyright Office to look at it
and say, you know,
do this prescreening
and say do we have a real
substantial fight on our hand
or is this essentially a, you know,
a no-brainer where there's no
significant, no meaningful,
whatever the right
word is, opposition.
And if there is, then again,
it just gets shunted back
into the regular process.
>> Regan Smith: And then,
would you think if the Office
in its prescreening determined
it was sort of insufficient
under administrative law principles
or something, we could go back
and say give us a little more,
like Mr. Band was saying, or--
>> Ben Sheffner: Yeah, again,
I mean, we haven't specified a,
you know, a whole set of processes.
And like Mr. Band, I wouldn't
want to make it too complicated.
But I mean, I think at a
high level, that's what--
I mean, I just explained what I
think the Copyright Office should be
trying to do is screen
out, OK, are we--
do we have a real fight
here or do we not?
And again, in the vast,
vast majority of cases
where somebody has gotten
an exemption already,
there is not going
to be a real fight.
There's not going to be an
opponent who has shown up.
And they're not going to bother
to show up unless they really,
really have a good reason
that I'm sure they'll be able
to identify in a page or two.
>> Regan Smith: People will
probably hold you to that.
Just kidding.
Mr. Turnbull?
>> Bruce Turnbull: I would agree
with that and only add that I think
that the nature and quantum
of evidence that would need--
or argument that would need to
come forward will depend a bit
on what the previous grant was.
If the previous grant is
this is really a close case,
but we think that, you know, it's
OK, you know, and we'll, you know,
we'll go forward, then you may not
need as much to come back and say,
yeah, there is a real argument here.
If the previous was, you know,
if it's already been granted three
times and this is the, you know,
the fourth time around and it's just
clear as a bell but that end up--
the opinion, the recommendation
is really clear, then it's going
to take more to come back and
say, no, there's really now--
there really now is a new argument.
There really now is new
evidence or whatever.
I just-- And again, I think that--
I mean, agreeing that it'll take--
it'll be in your discretion.
But, you know, I think that
that-- the level is going to be--
it'll be a pretty apparent
in any given case.
And your question about if somebody
submits something and you go, well,
on its face, that really
doesn't do it,
but we're not quite sure
what you're getting at, yeah,
I think that you ought to have
the discretion to go back and say,
you say that there's
new case law or you say
that there's some new technology but
you're really not describing that.
If we're going to reopen
this, you know,
into a full evidentiary
hearing, we need more than that.
And, you know, maybe,
you know, not giving--
not extending it out a long time
or giving, you know, repetitive.
But it seems to me that you would
have the discretion to do that.
I would hope that the lawyers
representing the opponents would
come forward and do well
in the first instance.
But if there was a
question, I think that it's
within your discretion
to ask for more.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Professor Tushnet?
>> Rebecca Tushnet: So just
briefly, I wanted to talk
about the characteristic or the
characterization of checking a box
as like somehow not
meeting your burden.
I mean, I don't think that's
just checking a box any more
than when you check a box
saying you've submitted truthful
information on your tax return, that
that's a meaningless or trivial act.
It's an affirmation that the
conditions at issue continue
to exist, or exist in the
case of the tax return.
So, it seems to me that in order
to refute the box, the checked box,
you should have to show those
conditions and laws have changed,
just like the IRS would want to show
that in fact that wasn't
your income.
And, you know, and if you want me
to, I will submit the entire record
from the last three
rulemakings as attachments
so you can consider them submitted.
But that seems kind of trivial.
I mean, I would be happier if
you considered the checkmark
to be me making that submission.
If we all agreed that that was what
I was doing, then it seems to me
that we then have a full submission.
It's just, you know, one
that's already in your books.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Mr. Geiger?
>> Harley Geiger: So in this
renewal process that we're talking
about here, we've talked about
having a one-page of why we,
you know, of meaningful opposition
of why circumstances have changed.
And if the Copyright Office then, in
its discretion, decides that it is
in fact meaningful, then they kick
it over to the normal process.
I would-- You know, unfortunately,
it would be a more complex process.
But I would suggest that in
between those two actions,
you actually give the proponent
the opportunity to respond,
the proponent the opportunity
to say, no,
the meaningful opposition is not
meaningful and here's why because,
you know, otherwise-- and hopefully,
that will inform the
Copyright Office
to better exercise its discretion
before beginning the long
and laborious process of going
through the whole temporary
exemption again.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Mr. Butler, I think you
may have the last word.
>> Brandon Butler: Yeah.
So, it's getting complicated
now, isn't it?
The one-pagers are proliferating,
which is good for those
of us who bill by the hour.
But I don't anymore, so-- and I
wonder-- ultimately, I think, my--
I guess this may be
too obvious to say.
But ultimately, the folks who
oppose I think are going to have
to come forward with
some real information
to explain why they think
circumstances have changed.
And so, I don't know-- I
just wonder how useful it is,
unless the Office is willing, I
think, to say based on a one-pager
and the opponents are willing to
be judged based on a one-pager,
like no, we're going no further.
That's just not enough.
We're not going to listen.
Then perhaps, the opponent should
just go ahead and come forward
with whatever reasons they
have, like the full bore,
because otherwise, how do we
know what those reasons are
and how do the proponents
respond, right?
So, if there is information
that the opponents have,
maybe they should go ahead and
disclose it or else, again,
maybe we can all agree that
sometimes that one page will just be
on its face lame and
you can reject it.
And then, maybe the one-page
thing is a good idea,
as long as everybody's OK with
being killed at that stage
and not going forward
to the full thing.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Well, we are two minutes early.
So, I'll consider that
a minor victory.
And this panel is concluded.
Tomorrow, we start again
at 9 in the morning talking
about the anti-trafficking
prohibitions.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.